is angelina jolie suing the fbi
based off newly released court documents
obtained by e.t it's a possibility
here's what we know a woman identified
as jane doe is filing a suit against the
fbi she claims they're withholding
information regarding their
investigation into an incident of
domestic violence on a private jet
several years ago involving the
plaintiff and her minor children as
victims and witnesses that incident
coincides with the description of the
altercation that led to angelina and
brad pitt's divorce in 2016. in the
lawsuit that was filed on march 7th and
2022 jane doe says she has public status
and wants to remain anonymous and here
are the details that are available the
suit says several years ago while
plaintiff her then husband and their
children who were all minors at the time
were traveling via private aircraft the
husband allegedly physically and
verbally assaulted plaintiff and the
children the documents go on to say the
fbi opened an investigation into the
assault but later without advance notice
to plaintiff or her children publicly
announced it was closing its
investigation of the incident without
further action jane doe has filed
several requests to gain access to the
fbi's investigative file in hopes of
better understanding the fbi's
investigation and obtaining information
necessary for her children to receive
medical care and trauma counseling the
plaintiff alleges that the responses she
has received to her request are legally
insufficient so she's now suing the fbi
for withholding the additional records
jane doe also sought to keep the case
sealed and proceed under an alias to
protect her public figure status and
family a judge has denied her request to
seal the case but granted her permission
to remain as jane doe the mystery
plaintiff's high-powered attorney amanda
kramer released a statement saying in
part victims and survivors should be
able to access federal agency records of
crimes they experienced or reported as
is common at the state level so they can
advocate for health and trauma care and
legal protections for their children and
themselves kramer goes on to say our
client has been seeking such records for
years and has been stonewalled and has
had to resort to court action receive
needed records but a source familiar
with angelina jolie and brad pitt's
long-standing custody battle over their
six children tells e.t angelina has been
given information regarding the
investigation saying the fbi
investigated brad in 2016 for the
incident that took place on their
private plane and found no wrongdoing
noting that both sides in the matter
have been given information regarding
the investigation e.t has reached out to
reps from both angelina and brad for
comment well we all have times in our
lives where we feel
broken angelina jolie and brad pitt
split in 2016 after two years of
marriage citing irreconcilable
differences in 2021 when discussing her
movie those who wish me dead the actress
opened up to e.t about her advice for
regaining strength after feeling
overwhelmed and broken for a period of
time
when you feel like you just want to kind
of hide under the covers or you're not
sure what you've got left in you go
somewhere see what you've got in you
put yourself against the elements or try
something you've never tried and kind of
try to rediscover that
that strength within